>> Hello, my name is Dan Ports.
I'm a researcher in
the Systems Research Group at
Microsoft Research Redmond.
I lead the Prometheus project
which is about how to take
advantage of new hardware in
the data center co-designed
with distributed systems.
So, what's motivating this
is that we are now in
a world where there's
a wide variety of
customized and
programmable hardware
available in the data center.
We're not just in
an era where there
are commodity servers
connected by a dumb network,
but we now have
programmable devices
including programmable
data plain switches,
smart Nix and FPGAs
deployed in the network.
So, what that means is that
there's the possibility
for the network itself to act
as a computational element,
to run some amount of processing
directly on each packet.
We're interested in this
from a systems perspective.
How can this be used to
accelerate distributed
systems applications?
The key to our approach
is that we're going to
co-design network primitives
with distributed systems,
to use this hardware to implement
some new functionality and
then build the
applications around that.
So, to give
some examples of this,
we're able to build
replicated systems that
are considerably faster
because we don't have to run
a traditional consensus protocol
like Paxos on every operation.
Instead, we can run a
simple primitive in
the network that assigns
sequence numbers to
requests as they come in,
and then use a much simpler
protocol that's able
to implement the replication
without the replicas having
to talk to each other.
This lets us improve
the performance of
a existing data center service
by a substantial amount.
We're able to reduce
systems from having
an 80% overhead for replication
to more like two percent.
We're also investigating
new applications
that require more computationally
intensive primitives.
So, for example,
deep neural network training
requires a lot of
communication bandwidth in
today's highly parallel clusters.
We're able to reduce this
communication overhead a lot,
by having the network
aggregate parameter updates
from the different servers,
combining them into
a single update rather than
having the full set of
data be distributed
all the servers.
This is able to to
increase the throughput of
this neural network
training by 3x,
which will dramatically
reduce training time.
We're also looking at
other applications
including load balancing,
where delivering
different requests
to different server
is based on the load,
is able to increase
the system utilization by
a considerable fraction
without running into
tail latency problems and
network telemetry
applications where
a part of the processing is
done in the network
switches themselves.
Overall, what we're able to do
with all of this is to build
systems with dramatically
lower orders of magnitude,
latency, and throughput overhead,
by moving computational elements
into the switch.
The key part of this is to
carefully think about
what primitives need to
be deployed in the network
versus what needs to be
done at the application
layer. Thank you.